We've read the
Iliad and the Odyssey. So, Homer
becomes the basis
for Greek civilization. Meaning that all
educated Greeks
they memorize the Iliad and the Odyssey.
They don't They don't read read and
write now at this point. They speak
and they listen
in front of an audience.
And so, Homer
becomes basically the infrastructure of
their mental worldview.
And this leads to the greatest
civilization in human history.
But eventually, the Romans will conquer
the Greeks. The Romans will conquer the
entire Mediterranean
and they will create the Roman Empire.
The Romans are nothing like the Greeks.
The Greeks are very open,
very curious.
They believe in the idea of arete.
Sorry.
Um
arete
and eudaimonia.
Arete means excellence.
To
be the best at what you can.
Eudaimonia means flourishing. You can
only achieve human happiness
if you achieve your arete. Okay? You
become your arete. So, think of Odysseus
who was great speaker. That is his
arete.
Um and he uses his speech in order to
fulfill his destiny and to save his
family. Okay? And that achieves
eudaimonia.
The Romans are very different. The
Romans believe in the idea of piety.
Okay? And piety just means obedience to
your fathers,
to history, and to tradition.
And so, the Romans are extremely
conservative people.
But, they're very good at fighting wars,
and that's why they become the empire.
Um, but after the empire is established,
what the Romans recognize is that Greek
culture is vastly superior.
And many well-educated Romans begin to
drift towards Greek culture,
which in the Roman perspective leads to
the corruption of the Roman soul.
And so, Augustus Caesar,
who is really considered the first
emperor of Rome,
he recognizes that
in the long term, even though the Romans
have conquered the Greeks
physically,
spiritually, the Greeks will conquer the
the Romans. And the main issue is Homer.
So, his solution is to
destroy Homer.
You can't burn books because
uh there aren't that there aren't that
many books, and also people have
memorized Homer.
So, you need to corrupt Homer.
And the solution that he devises is
called the Aeneid.
And we can consider the Aeneid as the
anti-Homer, okay, or the inversion of
Homer. Taking the ideas of Homer and
inverting them.
Okay? So, um this becomes the Bible
of the Roman Empire, meaning that if
you're a schoolboy,
you have to memorize the Aeneid. And
this is the main way that you learn
Latin, the official language of the um
Roman Empire. And so, whereas Homer will
give us Greek civilization and the birth
of Western civilization,
the Aeneid will create the Dark Ages. A
about a thousand years when Western
creativity
um ends.
And
then someone will emerge who will
recognize the evil that is the Aeneid.
And he will create a antidote to the
poison that is the Aeneid. And this
person, of course, is called Dante.
Okay?
And so, what we'll do is we will read
the Aeneid for next 2 weeks and
understand how it poisons and corrupts
Homer. And then this will lead us to the
Divine Comedy, which is really the
liberation of the human soul from the
poison that is the Aeneid. Okay? All
right. So, um
some basic background about the Aeneid.
So, the Aeneid, what it does is it
replicates
both the Odyssey and the Iliad. Uh the
Aeneid is 12 It's 24 books. The first 12
books models off the Odyssey. The last
12 books models off the Iliad. So, uh
the story begins when Aeneas,
he um is one of the survivors
of the fall of Troy.
Okay? And so, he takes his father and
his child to go off to the Italian
Peninsula because the gods have told him
that he he is fated he is destined to
found the Roman Empire. And that's why
the gods had to destroy Troy in order to
create the Roman Empire.
But as he um sails to the Italian
Peninsula,
uh there's a shipwreck and he lands in
Carthage. Okay?
Carthage.
And there he meets the queen, Dido.
And the Carthaginians and Dido are
extremely hospitable to Aeneas.
And so they have this huge banquet and
Aeneas is telling her of the story of
the fall of Troy, how Troy fell.
Remember remember that Homer doesn't
actually discuss the fall of Troy, but
Aeneas will discuss the fall of Troy.
And by discussing the fall of Troy, his
main purpose is to show how duplicitous,
manipulative, deceptive the Greeks are.
Okay?
He's he's also going to tell us
um
why the values of Homer are evil, why
love is evil, why love will lead you
into tragedy.
And then by telling the story, what will
happen is that uh Aeneas will seduce
Dido. Dido will fall in love with him.
Not Not only is he brave and handsome,
but he's also a great poet. He's able to
tell the story in a beautiful manner.
And so they fall in love, okay? All
right. So this is the beginning of the
in in uh
uh
uh Aeneid. And so what what what we're
going to read first is Aeneas's story of
the fall of Troy. It begins when the
Greeks pretend to leave the beaches of
Troy
and they leave behind a wooden horse,
okay? And there's a huge debate among
the Trojans as to what to do with this
horse.
And
they decide basically, you know, we
can't take a risk. Let's just destroy
the this horse, throw throw it uh into
the sea. And then what happens is that a
Greek soldier emerges. And he's a
prisoner. He's He was caught by some
shepherds and he tells the story of the
Trojan horse and why it's really not a
threat to the Trojans. In fact, it's a
gift from the Greeks to the gods. So,
because it's a gift to the gods, you
cannot destroy it because then you piss
off the gods.
Okay? And what this is going to show us
is that the Greek culture, philosophy,
theater, rhetoric, it's all one of
deception. The real Trojan horse
is Greek culture. You cannot let Greek
culture into Rome because then it will
corrupt and poison
the empire from within. Okay? So, that
that So, again, this is propaganda. So,
it's very blatant what they're doing,
okay? It's very blatant what Virgil
um is doing.
And okay, something I I need to explain
is that Virgil is considered the poet
who composed
the uh Aeneid. But, it was actually
Augustus Caesar who wrote this.
Basically, Augustus Caesar was the one
who provided Virgil with a framework,
and then Virgil
um
uh composed it into Latin poetry.
And actually,
at the end of his life,
Virgil actually wanted to burn this
down. Burn this.
And the reason why is that if you're a
poet, what you believe is that your gift
comes from the gods. And so, you
represent the gods. But, if you actually
work for the empire, you actually use
your gift for the emperor, then maybe
the gods will punish you.
Right? So, Virgil Virgil was very much
afraid and wanted to like burn the uh
Aeneid,
um but Augustus Caesar would not let
him. And so, this became the Bible of
the Roman Empire. It is a evil, evil
piece of work, okay? And it is the
anti-Homer. So, we're going to study it
um because it's going to shape Western
civilization
throughout the Middle Ages until the
coming of Dante, okay? So, all right.
So, I mean, can you read, please? Yeah.
Suddenly, in the thick of it all, a
young soldier, hands shackled behind his
back, with much shouting, Trojan
shepherds were hauling him toward the
king.
He'd come on demand by chance, a total
stranger. He'd given himself up with one
goal in mind, to open Troy to the Greeks
and lay her waste. He trusted to
courage, nerved for either end, to weave
his lies or face a certain death.
Young Trojan recruits, keen to have a
look, came scurrying up from all sides,
crowding round, outdoing each other to
make a mockery of the captive.
Now, hear the treachery of the Greeks
and learn from a single crime the nature
of the beast. Haggard, helpless, there
in our midst he stood. All eyes riveted
on him now, and turning a wary glance at
the lions of the of Trojan troops, he
groaned and spoke, "Where can I find
some refuge, where on land, on sea?
What's left for me now, a man of so much
misery?
Nothing among the Greeks, no place at
all. And worse, I see my Trojan enemies
crying for my blood."
His groans convince us, cutting all our
show of violence short.
>> Okay, so at this time in history, and
this this about um about 30 BCE,
um, Greek theater is very, very popular.
The Romans love Greek theater. And Greek
theater is really, um, the very paragon
of Greek civilization. And what this is
telling us is that, no, Greek theater is
evil. It's meant to deceive us, okay?
So, this soldier, this Greek soldier, he
is trained in theater, he's trained in
philosophy, he's trained in rhetoric,
and he's using all his craft, all his
skills, in order to ultimately deceive
the good, but but naive Trojans, okay?
All right. So, he tells the story
of how he came to be left behind
in Troy. And the story is that he pissed
off Odysseus. Odysseus plotted against
him. So, so when it came time for the
Greeks to leave Troy and sail home, they
need they need to sacrifice a person.
And that person was this guy. But
somehow this guy ran off, okay? Can you
Can you read Ivory?
The day of infamy soon came. The sacred
rites were all performed for the victim.
The salted meal strewn, the bands tied
around my head.
But I broke free of death, I tell you.
Burst my shackles. Yes, and hid all
night in the reeds of a marshy lake,
waiting for them to sail. If only they
would sail.
Well, no hope now of seeing the land
where I was born or my sweet children,
the father I longed for all these years.
Maybe they'll wring from them the price
of for my escape. Avenge my guilt with
my loved one's blood. Poor things. I beg
I beg you, king.
By the powers who know the truth.
By any trust still uncorrupt in the
world of men, pity a man whose torment
knows no bounds. Pity me in my pain. I
know in my soul I don't deserve to
suffer.
He wept and won his life our pity, too.
Priam takes command, has him freed from
the ropes and chains that bind him fast,
and hails him warmly.
Whoever you are, from now on, you've
lost the Greeks. Put them out of your
mind and you'll be one of us.
But answer my questions. Tell me the
whole truth. Why did they raise up this
giant monstrous horse? Who conceived it?
What's it for? Its purpose? A gift to
the gods? A great engine of battle?
Okay, so again, this reminds us of the
Iliad, where Priam, the king of the
Trojans, is known for being a very
generous,
magnanimous, uh sorry, um benevolent
um open person. But, this will lead to
the doom
of Troy. So, remember in the Iliad, it
is because of Priam's generosity, his
ability to forgive
Achilles, that leads to the great
friendship between Priam and Achilles,
okay? And again, Virgil sort of reverses
and he's trying to show us that, "No,
you think that generosity will lead to
goodness. No, generosity will lead to
evil." You see how Priam is too
trusting, too generous. And so, he
believes this Greek, uh,
soldier, and then he will allow the
Trojans to bring the horse into
Troy. And at night, the the Greek
soldiers will escape from the horse,
open the gates of Troy, and now the
Greeks are rushing in to kill everyone,
okay? And Aeneas
hears this, um,
slaughter, and he tries to save as many
people as he can. And his first thought
is, "Where is my king? How do I save my
king?" Okay? So, as the Greeks are
ravaging the city, killing as many
people as they can, Aeneas is rushing to
save his king, Priam. All right?
All right. So, can you read, uh,
all right?
Perhaps you wonder how Priam met his
end. When he saw his city stormed and
seized, his gates wrenched apart, the
enemy camped in his palace that
The old man donned his armor long
unused. He clasps it round his
shoulders, shaking with age, and all for
nothing, straps his useless sword to his
hip, then makes for the thick of battle,
out to meet his death. At the heart of
the house, an ample altar stood, naked
under the skies, an ancient laurel
bending over the shrine, embracing our
household gods within its shade.
Here, flocking the altar, Hecuba and her
daughters huddled, blown headlong down
like doves by a black storm, clutching,
all for nothing, the figures of their
gods.
Seeing Priam decked in the arms he'd
worn as a young man,
"Are you insane?" he she cries.
"Poor husband, what impels you to strap
that sword on now?
Where are you rushing?
Too late for such defense, such help.
Not even to my for my own Not even my
own Hector, if he came to the rescue
now.
Come to me, Priam. This altar will
shield us all, or else you'll die with
us."
With those words, drawing him towards
her there, she made a place for the old
man beside the holy shrine. Okay, let's
continue.
Suddenly, look, a son of Priam, Polites,
just just escaped from slaughter at
Pyrrhus's hands.
>> Okay, so Pyrrhus is a son of Achilles,
okay?
So, this is a rewriting of the ending of
the Iliad, where
Priam and Achilles have this great
emotional battle, where they forgive
each other. And
Priam's love for Hector and Achilles'
love for his father unifies
their soul, okay? This is going to be a
rewriting of that battle. So, Achilles
is dead, and now his son is seeking to
kill Priam. You want to keep on going?
Comes racing through spears, through
enemy fighters, fleeing down the long
arcades and deserted hallways. Badly
wounded, Pyrrhus hot on his heels, a
weapon poised for the kill, about to
seize him, about to run him through, and
pressing home as Polites reaches his
parents and collapses, vomiting out his
lifeblood before their eyes.
At that
>> Okay, so again, this is a rewriting of
the Iliad, where now Polites becomes
Hector, right? If you remember,
um Achilles kills Hector
at the gates of Troy, and Priam and
Hecuba are on the walls watching this.
And then Achilles commits
a war crime by basically tying Hector to
his chariot and then
um
um dragging Hector all around the wall
the walls of Troy. Okay, so this is a
re- re-imagining of that scene. Okay,
keep keep on going.
At that Priam traps in a group group of
death, not holding back, not checking
his words, his rage. "You," he cries,
"you and your vicious crimes. If any
power on high recoils at such an
outrage, let the gods repay you for all
your reckless work, grant you the
thanks, the rich rewards you the richer
rewards you've earned.
You've made me see my son's death with
my own eyes, defiled the father's sight
with a son's lifeblood. You say you're
Achilles' son? You lie. Achilles never
treated his enemy Priam so. No, he
honored a suppliant's right. He blushed
to betray my my trust. He restored my
Hector's bloodless corpse for for
burial, sent me safely home to the land
I rule."
>> Okay, so again
he is reminding us of the ending of the
Iliad where in this great war peace and
love come to universe when Achilles and
Priam
are able to become friends. Okay?
And he's saying
"Your father, you've you've destroyed
the legacy of your father. You've
destroyed the friendship between us.
Okay?" All right, keep on reading.
With that and with all his might the old
man flings his spear, but too important
now to pierce, it merely grazes
Pyrrhus's brazen shield that blocks his
way and clings there, dangling limp from
the boss, all for nothing.
Pyrrhus shouts back, "Well then, down
you go, a messenger to my father,
Peleus' son. Tell him about my vicious
work, how Neo
Neoptolemus degrades his father's
>> Neoptolemus is actually another name for
pirates, okay? It's the same person.
Keep on going.
degrades his father's name, don't you
forget.
Now, die.
That said, he drags the old man straight
to the altar, quaking, slithering on
through slicks of his son's blood, and
twisting Priam's hair in his left hand.
His right hand sweeping forth his sword,
a flash of steel.
He buries his hilt deep in the king's
flank.
Such was the fate of of Priam, his
death, his lot on Earth, with Troy
blazing before his eyes, her ramparts
down, the monarch who once had ruled in
all his glory, the many lands of Asia,
Asia's many tribes.
A powerful trunk is lying on the shore.
The head wrenched from the shoulders, a
corpse without a name.
>> Okay, so
there's a difference between the Greeks
and the Romans, okay? The Greeks are
very cultured people. They enjoy going
to theater and watching a tragedy and
crying together to rejuvenate their
sense of humanity, okay? That was the
Greek culture. The
Romans go to the Colosseum and watch
gladiatorial fights, okay? They like
blood. They like violence. And so, the
Aeneid is extremely violent
uh poetry.
In fact, you can say all it's almost
pornographic in the violence that it
depicts.
All right? And the Romans just love this
because they are a bloodthirsty people.
All right?
All right. So, Priam is dead, and with
its death, what it is doing is negating
the
um moral lesson of the Iliad, to forgive
one's enemy. Okay? So, the Romans read
this and they remember reading the Iliad
and saying, "Oh my god, I was wrong to
think that Priam was heroic in forgiving
Achilles." What I should be really
thinking is, "What a foolish old man who
deserves to die for thinking that his
enemy should be forgiven. That for for
thinking that his enemy has a good soul
in him."
Okay? So, again, this is negating
the Iliad. It's actually poisoning and
corrupting the Iliad.
All right? So, um
Now, Aeneas is talking about his
reaction watching
his king die. Okay?
Uh keep on reading, Ivory.
Then, for the first time, the full
horror came home at came home to me at
last.
I froze. The thought of my own dear
father filled filled my mind when I saw
the old king gasping out his life with
that raw raw wound.
Both men were the same age and the
thought of my Creusa alone, abandoned,
our house plundered, our little Iulus's
fate.
I looked back. What forces still stood
by me?
None. Totally spent in war, they'd all
deserted. Down from the roofs, they
flung themselves to earth or hold their
broken bodies in the flames.
So, at just that moment, I was the one
man left and then I saw her clinging to
Vesta's threshold, hiding in silence,
tucked away, Helen of Argos.
Glare of the fires lit my view as I
looked down, scanning the city left and
right, and there she was. Terrified of
the Trojans' hate, now Troy was
overpowered,
terrified of the Greeks' revenge, her
deserted husband's rage,
that universal fury occurred to Troy and
her native land. And here she lurked,
skulking, a thing of of loathing,
cowering at the altar, Helen.
Out it flared, the fire inside my soul,
my rage ablaze to avenge our fall our
fallen country. Pay Helen back, crime
for crime. Okay. So,
Aeneas is watching his entire
civilization being destroyed, and he
knows that his family will be destroyed
as well.
And he is taken aback. He's sort of like
paralyzed by his anger and his hatred
and his fear. And then he sees Helen,
and he's like, "This is her fault, okay?
This is why we are
we are destroyed as a civilization
because of this okay?" And so,
this is telling us what? That this the
lesson from this is that love
is a source of evil in the world.
Okay? Love is a source of evil in this
world.
Remember the Odyssey. What is the What
is the um
main lesson of the Odyssey? Love is the
redemptive force of the world, right?
If you are shattered as a person, it is
love that will lead you home and heal
you as a person. And what the Aeneid is
saying instead is that love is what
destroys civilization. Love is what
corrupts you.
Love is what leads you to hell,
okay?
All right. So, he wants to kill Helen
as revenge for destruction of Troy, but
then what happens is that Aeneas's
mother, Venus, okay? So, Venus is his
mother,
steps in, appears before him, says, "No,
you can't do this. You have to go home
and save your wife and your child."
Okay? So, Aeneas goes home and what he
does is he say he takes his family and
takes them to the ship to escape Troy.
But, as they are running through the
streets of Troy
what Aeneas does is he puts his father
on his back. Okay? And he holds his son,
his young son Iulus.
And the and Creusa, the wife
has to follow them. Okay? So, that
that's the Roman priority. Okay?
The most important person in a family is
the patriarch, the father.
Then is the son who inherits. And the
wife is just someone who follows. Okay?
But her job is to serve rather than be
an equal in the relationship. And this
is again is very different from the
Odyssey where in many ways Penelope and
Odysseus are equal to each other. Okay?
All right. So, what happens is that
Aeneas gets to the ship and he and he
puts his father and his son on the ship
ready to escape. But he recognizes
at the at the very last minute his wife
is missing.
So, he goes back and tries to save
his wife. But his wife is dead. And why
she dead? Because she killed herself.
Why did she kill herself? Because it is
her duty not to burden her husband.
Because her husband is destined for
great things. He's destined to found an
empire. So, he must marry into a new
lineage, a new royal family. And
therefore, she has to kill herself to
free him. But not only that,
but if she were to become a slave to the
Greeks, it would cause him embarrassment
for the rest of his life, right? Okay?
So,
that is the Roman perception of a wifely
duty. Okay? If you're not useful to your
husband, just kill yourself.
Okay. Uh can you read?
Creusa, nothing, no reply. And again,
Creusa.
But then, as I madly rushed from house
to house, no one in sight, abruptly,
right before my eyes, I saw her stricken
ghost, my own Creusa's shade.
But larger than life, the life I'd known
so well. I froze. My hackles bristled,
voice choked in my throat. And my wife
spoke out to ease me of my anguish.
"My dear husband, why so eager to give
yourselves to such mad flights of grief?
Is not without the will of the gods that
these things have come to pass.
But the gods forbid you to take Creusa
with you, bound from Troy together.
The king of lofty Olympus won't allow
it.
A long exile is your fate. The vast
plains of the sea are yours to plow when
you reach Hesperian land, where Lydian
Tiber flows with a smooth march through
rich and loamy fields, a land of hardy
people.
There, great joy and a kingdom are yours
to claim, and a queen to make your wife.
Dispel your tears for a Creusa whom you
loved. I will never behold the high and
mighty pride of their palaces, the
Myrmidons, the Dolopians, or go as a
slave to to some Greek matron. No, not
I, daughter of Dardanus that I am, the
wife of Venus's son.
The great mother of gods detains me on
these shores. And now, farewell.
Hold dear the son we share, we loved
together." Again, this is very different
from the Odyssey, where
the Odyssey is really about a journey of
two people, Penelope and Odysseus, to
find each other again, because love is
the greatest force in the universe.
Okay? Love is what compels the two to
reunite, and to find each other amidst
all the chaos um surrounding them.
In the Aeneid, the idea is that love is
hell. So, what is heaven, okay? If love
is hell,
what is heaven?
Heaven is piety.
Piety just means
obedience to the prophecy of the gods,
right? It is the will of gods that Troy
be destroyed so that Rome can be
created. It's a It is the prophecy of
the gods that Aeneas will be the one to
lead the Trojans to found this Rome. And
therefore, what is good, what is divine,
is obedience to this prophecy, okay? So,
a long exile is your fate.
All right? The king of my lofty Olympus
won't allow. Zeus, okay, or Jupiter,
demands this of us. If
Jupiter demands us to sacrifice
ourselves, then we must do so, okay?
And so, this
reverses
the Odyssey,
right? Where the gods will it that
Penelope and Odysseus reunite.
But here,
the gods will it that Creusa and Aeneas
separate.
All right?
Okay? So,
from our eyes, this doesn't sound
that influential. But the reality is,
remember,
this becomes the basis of Roman
civilization.
All right? And what is civilization but
a set of values, a set of ideas that
guide you in your life?
Okay? And what this is doing is
inverting Homer, poisoning and
corrupting Homer.
All right? Okay, any questions, guys?
Okay, so we'll we'll continue this next
week, okay?